racist-ass movie all right posted calm
alright guys so do us a favor if any of
you saw even if you didn't see it yeah
episode 2 was based on the top 5 male
insecurities and we would very much like
if possible someone to share with us the
top 5 female of female insecurities so
we can talk about that man that will be
extremely interesting Airy interesting
yeah I like that a lot
I like that a lot yeah because we'll we
will talk about it from our perspective
and determine whether it should be an
insecurity or not yeah for sure man and
I'll be honest brother if I'll say
you're right that should be in the agree
because don't let me care don't let me
catch you slipping catch you with that
alright cool so let me start off with
something like mmm and then get into
something a little bit more yeah
substantial yeah mom this is a pet peeve
ruff three words that I hate more than
anything anything so obviously you know
what I said about being lost yeah
insects and all of this stuff three
words
I [ __ ] hate your insect during sex
this stress me out more than anything
let me see if I can guess yeah is it so
it's obviously a turn-off well it's not
necessarily a turn-off it's not no no no
no I don't want to I don't want to
bridge and say it's a turn-off but it
throws me out of my loop I don't know
not my loop but it throws me out of of
getting lost
yes you just have no fam make me [ __ ] I
was thinking that by thinking love yeah
make me calm yeah can't stand it I can't
stand it stressful family I don't need
that level of pressure yeah I don't need
that level of pressure I shine I intend
to better I live I intend to
that's the fingers oh yeah I'm sure
actively try it if I have it my way
you're gonna knock three times before I
do but guess what this is real life now
I'm stressed yeah now I'm sweating and
all I can do is focus on my stroke on my
game like I'm a compare of guy but I say
made me come I'm gonna make you come but
right Rev like I'm stressed I'm so
stressed so stressed I never see that
what's so funny
good cuz let's say even back it 4:15
yeah yeah and she's like oh make me come
but you've been trying to make a comfort
15 and it's like oh [ __ ] it's only just
gotten real but you know what I speak
only people that I have made come say
make me come so it's never anything it's
no it's never you
it's never a newbie that will throw out
there it's a comfortable person okay
that like you've make um yeah
but the times I have made them coming
I'll probably be lost in it yeah but
when you make it like and you verbalize
yeah cuz because now basically use it
makes it worse because they know I can
yeah so now they've they know I can they
know that I know that that I can yeah
and now they've formally requested it
yeah so if I don't do it now at this
point I'm a piece of [ __ ] yeah why
didn't you make me come that's funny
yeah and I'm trying yeah it's same as
like oh don't stop or [ __ ] me harder cuz
it you I'm about to make you do you know
what annoys me so much like unless I'm
[ __ ] to go a missionary and she's
like oh it's not that's up but I've been
I've been pounded for about a good 45
seconds oh don't get me wrong
when I say 45 seconds girls you think oh
my god that's that's very short but
stroking for flat second I mean like
well have you said in previous episode
you can't count 1 to 30 in one breath so
imagine bang in pump in for 45 seconds
big man I'm already tired
I'm already parched and I'm probably
gonna get ass [ __ ] so wait when you
keep telling me I feel like so much
pressure I don't stop don't stop
obviously the plan is not to stop yeah
yeah yeah I was not gonna stop anyway
but you don't need to Tommy don't stop
because
that's pressure now because if I do stop
well mail it down I'm a letdown because
if I wanted to stop and switch up
positions you know the euphoria is gone
now and now you're in the translation
and it's like I wasn't gonna stop
regardless and now I have to continue
yeah you have to pull my muscle and
still continue but it's an omen because
it's like girls coming is like it's like
a it's a mechanical procedure there's
algorithms yeah yeah so once you find
that robot yeah and you're like you know
early on this is the wise this is the
one copy see it's the ones you're gonna
cut but yet if anything [ __ ] up your
rhythm when you stroke yeah you might
offer a yeah yeah climax goes from if
you're right if it goes if they're
feeling that theme infinite and once you
slip bang whereas a guy again if it hits
that point it's not there's no every
time brother there's no really what I
said before when I said girls need to
fix up that [ __ ] game and have a full
plate [ __ ] yeah because we're not
like you lot
if you suck me off I'm close to come in
I'm come when I [ __ ] you I will come
soon yeah yeah very soon yeah that was
quick
no no [ __ ] me off not like you we
don't we don't start from ground zero
yeah full plate brings us up so yeah
you've got me 98 percent of the way
there for foreplay broth when I stick it
you know I really need to go to more
percent I'm pop I'm bussing I'm busting
off to three or four C gamma not minutes
so I'm just guys ladies foreplay let's
stay low yeah turn the [ __ ] want but
keep the come radar low the Kamiya keep
it low firm and we have fantastic sex
was it here's that point you mean the
tingle tingles
give me those tinkles brough do you know
what I do to suppress myself rope coming
sometimes as well this is a little tip
it depends it depends what position
you're in it only ever works probably in
it works in cowgirl and I've only ever
done in Co gradually because yeah it's a
reach-around teen okay so it's when
obviously you're grabbing our ass in
cargo yeah
to flick your ball one time we just
flick it twice
BAM it will disorientate the whole
mechanism because there have been times
I'm close
cause I just just a quick a quick flick
oh my god quick flicks a quick flick it
just suppresses it I don't know why it
for me anyway then if that's a generic
male species thing but for me just quick
bangbang
just quick to tak a quick double tap and
it's your karmic and you can go for
another five and swear down or you just
have to switch up positions either raw
but obviously it's hot the thing is when
obviously the girl is in the moment and
you switch positions - ah yes something
she's lost in that position she wants to
not yeah once it's not makes me one or
not yeah and then it's like that's the
thing fact if I make you not I'm gonna
neither you're disappointing because I
can't go anymore but I have to come in
the same time as you because when you're
coming I'm like I said I'm a pleaser
brother yeah if you're coming arm drags
you're coming on coming so I will make
you come from
brother Tong fingers all sorts but dick
I'm coming with you
I'm coming with you one of them ones he
did yeah yeah but yes honey guys no more
pressure please this time
no more [ __ ] pressure please another
one alright this is me gustas a bit more
substantial
[Laughter]
okay cool
this one's actually a little bit funny
okay so we both know mmm you and I are
like different when it comes to like
talking to girls on our now okay yeah
the approach the game
yeah whole game yes I want to talk about
the whole game the setup the play okay
if we're trying to pull yeah your moves
versus my moves
okay ladies moves like whatever yeah you
you like to chat yeah I get anxiety you
love to chat
I get anxious that's funny I can't
that's me funny considering this is what
I like to do yeah sit here and chat yeah
but if I don't know you
yeah yeah for some reason my brain
doesn't work it's hard here if I'm
attracted to you and I don't know you
it's worse ten times I can't speak yeah
and I'm just like I don't even know I'm
struggling to get the words out now
visualizing it III can't do it like I
don't know I've just never been able to
talk to girls on now yeah
and this they're talking to me yeah
which nine times out of ten is what
happens yeah both so like yeah ladies
just for some like perspective I've had
my fair share and I wonder sounds or
whatever and I was supposed to a fair
enough amount of girls on a night out
but I don't think I've ever approached
to go directly and had it kind of
flourished from there okay
it's never happened it's never happened
yeah I just I don't panic I just don't
know what the [ __ ] to say that
icebreaker you don't know what yeah I
don't know what the [ __ ] to say and even
once I have said even if the icebreaker
goes off well yeah I don't know how to
continue talking I don't know
to do conversation it don't make sense
quick tangent hmm
going off like that icebreaker thing so
let's say for example it's not a tangent
it's kind of like a follow-through let's
say the you start talking for a say but
they're the quick icebreaker is oh let
me get you a drink because obviously out
you're in a bar in a club whatever yeah
yeah so one I was in a car one day and I
was talking to one of my boys or one of
my boys boys rather and he said he
doesn't even buy a girl's drinks anymore
hmm when he goes out and he said it cuz
he feels like I've got no worth but to
buy your time so I'm essentially buying
your time too but because I'm buying you
a drink you have to actively stay with
me or get the drink run so we can talk
something actively buying your time hmm
which some people may agree with and
some people may know agree if but I feel
like him saying that I understand the
concept I feel like it's an extreme that
sounds extreme it sounds very extreme so
I just want to put out there and just
don't know if you guys give have any
feedback on that wherever but yeah yeah
so like as I was saying yeah I'm not
good ciao yeah I've even done like yeah
like I said that the drink thing I've I
drink kind of faint yeah yeah yeah and
they want to wait for a drink boy is
that awkward I'm just leaning on the bar
like look just pop in just pop it to the
chin think you know yeah pop into the
tuna I'm there um this is me like so the
bars here yeah you know me my elbows on
the bar yeah I put on more weight on my
elbows this is not even like I'm asking
ready it's just comfort I just put my
weight on there I'm on my tippy-toes and
I'm looking down the bar this side this
side she's here all right I don't know
what to say have a good time what yeah
having a good time yeah yeah yeah yeah
boom yeah double yeah yeah we having a
good time tonight
double double wide a yeah yeah but now
that's like but yeah I'm not saying I
don't have any game yeah
I'm said I can't chat yeah so I have to
play the mute game yeah which is gonna
sound hilarious yeah boom really it
works it works so as I just talked to my
brother about this day this is funny
this is funny funny so my brother's
newly single
he was just like what's the general yeah
that was the general thing but he can
chat but he's just like what's like he's
intrigued he's just intrigued by it
yeah about the club scene or wherever
and the dyeing arm and I'll get back
I'll get back to my me to get back to
this point because I've seen his tinder
has killed the club scene yeah but
anyway we'll get back to it so this is
my move - my play you already know it I
don't want to waste my breath
but yeah these listen to play this is
the place so guys if you can't chat give
it a go I haven't perfected it and by
any means but it does alright yeah so
you in you know the move so we mean you
were rolling in yeah straight to the bar
yeah get drink cool cool cool cool cool
scan scan scan give you 15 20 minutes
whatever eye contact yeah so we've got a
piece of eye contact yeah so now
alright cool there's eye contact you
find yourself at the bar the same time
there at the bar so there might be what
six people down five people down same
thing elbows and tippy-toes lean over
skirt scan scan make eyes and then you
hold the eye contact so you hold it let
her look away first mm keep staring keep
staring key said did she make I got
again all right cool that's checkpoint
number one no so you make the the the
second icon yet and then you hold it
hold it hold it and then you like you
like it's gonna make you laugh anyway
hmm but like you try and make out like
you try not to laugh yeah so you smile
yeah based to stop yourself from laugh
yeah so you just give it a little smart
and that's when you look away see you
like I like [ __ ] like yeah you win right
yeah you caught me clapping let me stare
out
and that's as far as I get ice the onus
is on demo the last one day needs to
come over because I'm a creep after that
so I know it sounded like it was gonna
be longer and more impressive but it
should be it that's all there is
maybe oh I don't even know maybe what's
actually mad is that you're not lying
because I'm thinking of back in your
past then like it's not necessarily
that's been your movement like you've
you get approached as opposed to doing
approaching whereas it's vice versa for
me oh yeah I do the approaching you do
I've done the approaching I mean but the
thing is it's not like I'm not that
overconfident blase kind of person
anyway
if I am doing the approach in it's
because I'm in my element I'm in my zone
like I've ever reached that optimum
drink level or high level and I'm like
I'm nice yeah and I'm just smiling I'm
happy for example we were to ambush loss
yeah you were bit you you were in your
element yeah my element so just I was
just I was about I was active do you
care you would have better the ball firm
and I'll just charge anything even if it
doesn't come to anything that chat
enough for me is calm like that set my
night out for a great night yeah cuz I
know nothing's gonna stop me now cuz I'm
gassed
I'm not Gus cuz the fact that I spoke to
you shakes I'm gas because the fact that
I'm on that perfect wavelength when
nothing is gonna go it's not gonna go
down any mental it's a bit yeah for sure
man and that's the way I play it
I hate you so and it's not like that
every said when I go out I just have to
reach that optimum level of waviness and
I'm smooth for the rest of the mile
smooth for the rest of my so question
question yeah obviously you did chat guy
what the [ __ ] you say to these people
that's the thing I don't necessarily
remember yeah kids because I'm in the
zone I just I just chatted it's not like
I asked them their name or like what you
doing it like I don't ask them a generic
basic stupid questions
I I don't know I actually don't know
things I don't know
please wait a minute okay I can give you
an example and the our [ __ ] last time i
approached so for example i hours
without rest loss i saw two girls I like
them both because they were both but you
know the story so I'm just saying yeah I
liked both of them because they were
both buff by Adiemus weeks and this is
when we first got in the club first go
in the bar over so me we were chillin
chillin chillin chillin chillin and then
we had a few shots and a few more shots
and a few more shots but then I saw
these two girls talking to two guys so I
just automatically assumed maybe that
that's them that's their party done
that's their party done for me I mean
but then they came to the bar which was
close to where we were standing and
talking and chillin yeah and I went over
to them and asked them Oh ladies real
quick question are those of both of
those guys your man and both of them
both said no and I said boom yeah dude I
mean yeah so that then for me was just
okay cool were in a level playing field
now hmm because they could have lied
true or they could have told the truth
if the truth was yesterday's them but
they had the option to lie mm-hmm if
they didn't lie it doesn't necessarily
mean they're interested but it doesn't
necessarily mean they're not interested
yeah he got me forever the item is yeah
do you have to be the optimist mmm and
then from then I made them laugh off the
bat because because like I said I liked
both of them so I was looking up but I
do know which one and I told you was
wrong and I I'm I what's the word I'm
looking for I'm very observant mm-hmm so
I look at a female detailed yeah that's
just me yeah and I see lip read what
they ordered not because I wanted to but
because it's just why I noticed and they
ordered vodka lemonade yeah and I said
our ladies want a drink both of you
what vodka lemonade yeah they both
laughed I was like do you know the
reason why not it's gonna show you guys
before and I saw that's what you ordered
so you know anyone they were guests
about that yeah yeah and and that's just
an example obviously I don't say that
every single on me out on over every
night out but that's just an example of
my way in because I'm observant and if
I've reached optimum point like I said
nothing that's not me and once I got
that in when she said when they both
said no
that's not there man it's free for what
now we're talking my fluid mmm right but
the only difference was the only hard
part was it was two against one
mmm so but then it didn't even know
obviously amounts to anything but the
conversation at a point was buff hmm
because we're talking we're friend was
good but yeah that's just an example
there's no it's a good example yeah it's
weird why man because yeah it's one of
those things that at this point I don't
even know if there's anything that I
want to be good before it's definitely
not anything I want to be good at now
but like it's just one of the things
that although it is like potentially
maybe help me back because you like you
said like I I put myself in a situation
I have to get approached yeah and I know
that's uncomfortable for an all-women to
do approach a guy that's another thing
actually quick tangent why the [ __ ] a
women scared of rejection I don't know
since when do women get rejected from
valid point firm the amount of times the
amount of times all right this something
will happen so in these times where we
might be in a club wherever I contact
eye contact etcetera etcetera etcetera
cetera she never ends up coming over
swine I never end up going over so we
leave it I mean you might be leaving and
we walk outside see the same coke and
give her a nod I'm Way more drunk this
time yeah I might I might say you're
right and then she would be like you're
right
and then she might call me over or
whatever after that and just say like ah
so what you want to talk to me now you
can talk to him yeah and I'm like big
man what you gonna spoke to me yeah and
then we got back up for that pathetic
[ __ ] yeah and then she'll say something
like I was never gonna come over to you
yeah like you could have told me to [ __ ]
off for that and I'm like big man no guy
named on you you've made it this far in
your life I know for a fact you've not
ever heard that other guy's mouth so
what made you think that was even a
possibility you're banging we needed to
gather your Buffalo though that was
hilarious
yours spicy man what she meet you Father
takes your [ __ ]
now be Oh what planet would that never
happened but for me on the other hand
yeah man no Gary ejected for bounce bro
banter brav guys get rejected scary
amounts but it's the jungle man where's
the drunken philosopher first it's
disgusting yeah it's convert and that's
the reason I have anxiety that's the
reason but there was one time that's
making me sweat just one time
obviously there was the time in Miami
this wasn't even to me but there's a
time in Miami where REM yeah there was
we were in man I think mansion the big
big mansion and then for some reason
these girls were showered out as group
of like Asian girls there was like six
or seven but one of their birthdays and
it REM turns around we were sad we're
next we'll go ahead and our friend goes
happy birthday and the girl turns around
backs up it's just like ill how dare you
how [ __ ] dare you think is they
already have a buff in my perspective
but it's like America is different
though the mentality over there is is
wild yeah it's true I do it here as well
man he was I remember one time we were
out I think all of us were out you I
know some black go and her weave was all
tore up at the back it was this was in
Coventry oh and we were one of those
raves and I sort of go and her hair was
just atrocious yeah so I went to
literally tap on a shoe apartments what
tap on the shoulder just like babe like
yeah you need to go you need to go
toilet so I like is [ __ ] up yeah as
I've gone to tap her and her friend at
how he's like a touchdown Alfredo it
literally is like a touchdown a frame
fairy so a friend immediately caught to
head back yeah and she grabbed my hand
and she was like she's gone man and then
they stomped off and the girl with the
[ __ ] we've was obviously feeling fresh
yeah thinking that his last game Punk's
trying to yeah trying to get his
he's like it's two cents in I'm trying
to help you out so these are the kind of
things where I can't even let you know
that you look like [ __ ]
but without you thinking that I'm trying
to move to you yeah yeah and like this
is why I can't this is why I've never
been able to women because they're
savages because they are savage because
they are and what's even worse about
less a perfect example like you said the
girl touched the girl ah she's got a man
ready to have 9 times that not 9 times
out of 10 but more often than not the
girl you're trying to move to actually
wants you to move to her but the bread
rinse her but as friends
you [ __ ] partial ones that she's gone
how do you know what your girl wants she
she's come out to get dick the same way
man dem have come out to get [ __ ] just
like you came out to come out you came
out to get dick only because you've not
been moved to you doesn't mean your
bread ring can't get moved to cock-block
Ian's friend's brother but the game is
the game the game is you got shoes you
shot when you can exactly I shot you're
not shoot me but the fingers as well as
like after all these years of [ __ ] up
I've now I feel like I've honed this
skill down yeah like a true talent
yeah so like when I said to you that
time mm-hm the same as last time
mmm when someone did speak to me I told
you I clocked it from as soon as they
walked in like I know how the plays were
step by step so now I come if I need to
I can position myself to make sure it
happens and there was a yeah I just I
just knew from the second I walked in
how everything was gonna play up and it
played out play for play and I mean I
think that's anything to be proud of it
makes me sound a bit of like a creep
when I say out loud but hey man yeah
basically my shy guy everyone plays the
game differently everyone's got their
own tactics like obviously you always
never go out with a tactic unless you're
actually easy to be the most controlled
the world like the goddess what'd you
say he must control everything so he
gives you a good look
exactly if you're tiny be good-looking
tiny bit will calm your calm this reason
it's hard out if a man a sword it's hard
I saw a meme the other day obviously
girls love tall man
hmm but a lot of tall man aren't even
buff they're just tall and girls like
gasthof tall so it's all guys so true
and then I saw it someone tweeted or
someone pointing histogram a cytochrome
it was just because your tool doesn't
mean your buff you're just ugly but from
further away I was like
brap thank you finally finally someone
gets a yes it's mad like goes obviously
you guys have your game plan sometimes
but it's hard it's so hard for guys it's
so high it's junk Wow yes guys ladies
please make it easier by the way is that
what you're gonna talk about when you
said going out as a Diane age or joining
after that no oh yeah team does tin just
[ __ ] up yeah alright so this is my
this is this is my insight from it
Tinder's [ __ ] up the club game yeah
because for starters girls don't
necessarily wanna [ __ ] a guy that they
really do not know yeah
so you meet a guy on a night out and you
don't know [ __ ] about you don't know
[ __ ] apart from the half an hour they
spoke to him I don't know how when
there's you can barely hear where he was
[ __ ] saying so girls would definitely
prefer not to [ __ ] that guy yeah now we
have tinder and all them you can not
only like do not have to [ __ ] that guy
you can make sure that you position
yourself if it's a Saturday night and
you've got like enough guys
that you're talking to on tinder you
genuinely don't need to [ __ ] the guy in
the club because if you're if for
example if it's Saturday night you'd
even a mate you see yeah you can pretty
much guarantee that at least three of
these guys are gonna be within walking
distance yeah in bars and clubs within
walking distance of where you are yeah
so if you need dick
you saw it you didn't waste time this
guy the night yeah you will do if you
find him attractive is you'll just get
Instagram yeah and we'll add them to the
pan into the yeah and you'll recycle the
pile yeah and you'll put him up step 7
yeah you'll go [ __ ] number guy that's
that's step one and hopefully Tyrone
will make it up to one by the time next
let me go back it's so easy so easy for
women it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
yeah man Tinder's [ __ ] up all day and
I'm so [ __ ] up the club game for sure
I haven't felt the effect but this is
just what's in my head as I reckon I he
because obviously I'm speaking about
tinder quite a bit um since you start
his podcast and for me I don't think I
understand where you're coming from
where it's [ __ ] up the club game or
the club scene or like an angle or the
approach to try and yeah yeah but I just
find it like another challenge or like
another another aspect of trying to
speak to a girl whereas obviously 10
tinder isn't Kristin a lot of people
think if you match for the girl on
tinder or if you're on tinder you're
banging yeah yeah not banging this is
like your pop or you're just out here
[ __ ] yeah yeah dude I mean that's a
miss preconception let's say you match
with ten things that's probably one of
them it's gonna [ __ ] you maybe maybe
maybe because nine times out of ten you
don't have the time of day to be talking
to ten chicks at the same time establish
that relationship to try and [ __ ]
alternate but yeah yeah because it's
highly impossible unless you're jobless
yeah it's highly impossible they find
out you're jobless you'll [ __ ] none
of them anyway yeah yeah goes with money
but you say you don't want money you
want money no you want to go with their
status so I forgot blush I thought [ __ ]
ten goes you might [ __ ] one yeah so you
might [ __ ] one so even if you do [ __ ]
that one 10 D yes tinder has helped you
but coming out is still another Avenue
you can follow yeah I am not even
necessarily banging all on or whatever
just the thrill of being around girls to
attempts to secure transaction do you
not I mean to be fair you're actually
true like that being said as a
counteract to what I just said
our a counter-argument
is that you can't really substitute from
true human intercourse not never never
you can't con doesn't like it because
perfect example obviously this is just a
scenario you match with the girl on
tinder
you start talking talking and you
establish between the both of you it's
pure crud you it's pure crud your your
hair for her she's here for you here so
you start talking the wickedness
yeah the moment you see her it's [ __ ]
awkward bro because there's never been
any physical contact you've never seen
him for she's and I've seen you before
she like she assesses where you live or
where ever you meet her kind of thing so
there's still that awkward hour or so
yeah where you have to kind of break the
ice before you even jump back into
talking about sex because you can't just
often about like traipse remember we're
talking about yesterday you know because
she's not even good wearing clothes last
night you was talking ordered it so it's
I hear where you're coming from in a
sense they it like that physical contact
what up what one-on-one is always going
to be the prime mmm the prime thing
because like I said you can talk the
wickedness on social media but until you
see the person but to be fair yeah
that's when the nervous exactly what you
mean when you mean for the first time it
just like so the first time is always
the yeah boy and then when you do get
that Club one especially when this have
been a few drinks involved is that by
the time you get in taxi but your dicks
in a hand
we met 17 minutes ago we're here and
then like just because you had that
little bit of one-to-one interaction but
all bets are off off yeah and your do
you manage going yeah yeah go straight
back to the item with [ __ ] it we're not
the whole care of what I [ __ ] and
that's just from like a tiny little bit
of interaction because the chemistry was
there from the bat and that's the
physical sexual face-to-face attraction
mmm whereas to know if if you're
messaging it could still be sexy but you
can't keep that conversation going for
for so long after 20 minutes is like
it's boring up yeah either I feel like
I'm forcing it or she's just probably up
gonna reply and it's just it's just dead
and he be like you give it a pre eyes
together that you given one other months
like he's still there kinda that's a
weird fingers I always thought about man
when it
just like people who just want to [ __ ]
vias like social media and then the only
rapport you have is just talking smack
yeah to each other you're right after 20
minutes half an hour
[ __ ] even an hour it just dies off
and you don't really let me know about
you don't know the person's here what
the [ __ ] else are you gonna talk about
and you have to try to stir it back up
yeah and use desperate attempts to get
it back on topic so what are you doing
I just eat and chips why I bet yeah yeah
yeah one of them chips give it a Priya's
wish Michael come over yeah yeah well
you got too many chips here where you
guys share now gonna come free what give
me a dress by yourself I told you I love
chips bring me free days let me eat his
chips a few tits oh my god yes funny I
used to hate those I remember when I
when I was on tinder before yeah I would
literally like she said I I would I
would have all of these interactions
these text interactions as soon as the
girl was like cool you wanna go for a
drink during the days I would say yes
yeah I would never turn it off yeah I
would never turn up because I'm just
like what the [ __ ] up we couldn't talk
yeah cuz you can talk and smack for the
past 7 days all we've been talking about
is you sucking dick for the last week
you're not gonna like
and I'm also thinking what are the
chances that you're actually gonna sleep
like that in person I mean I heard any
do bliss unlikely yeah is it unlikely so
now I have to get to know you know has a
good today I don't really want to you
establish like [ __ ] yeah like where do
you have a boner anymore like yeah I
don't even I don't care ok it's like I
don't want to know anything about you I
don't know what you do for a living I
don't know whereabouts you live I don't
know what you're interested in Adyar
genuinely don't care
Jenny don't give a [ __ ] no one will go
for a drink the amount of vagina
I must have locked off turned down just
because I don't give a [ __ ] yeah I just
don't give a [ __ ]
outrageous pants-a funny but so true
she's not so true alright let me finish
up on the car very quick funny yeah Oh
[Laughter]
God girls that watch is my thing we are
[ __ ] animals we are no but like we
are but we're not
this is the thing cuz this is just our
medium joke about I don't think girls
take the toy hunter
yeah for the 23 other hours of the day
yeah we don't were not like this this is
get along on my life this is only
because we know it's relatable yeah yeah
we know yeah this is my outlet yeah
that's why I talk about this is my
outlet and I do enjoy talking about yeah
but yes girls love listening to it yes
the thing goes I like listen dear babies
I like talking about I like you know I
like about it I like coming to
conclusions that I wouldn't have
otherwise come to mmm I like saying
something the amount of times I would I
would say something like this is how I
feel about this and then I talk about it
and then you would say how you feel
about it and if at the end of the time
we talk about it I don't even feel the
same way I felt when I said I've got a
completely different point of view and
that's talking to you someone who would
most likely agree with what I'm saying
anywhere and I still end up flipping it
that's what I enjoy by a man is just
bringing up something that I thought I
knew about and then by the end of your
sight I have a completely different
opinion do I have four seconds ago quick
one bro Jesus I'll say come over
tomorrow cuz I think it's really good
person or you know okay this one but
have you seen the amount of women
teachers in America getting arrested for
[ __ ] teenage boys not recently but in
my lifetime yes I've seen a few I've not
seen reach that being recently when you
say in your last time you mean in your
experience not like you were the guy
that [ __ ] them cuz I know you would
have told me that before I'm glad I
concluded what did you mean like like
I've heard it happen before like but not
recently Oh recently I'm saying recently
in in America especially I in the last
like a few months I've heard of three
separate teachers female teachers get
arrested for [ __ ] like 14 to 17 year
old guys where were these teachers when
I was in school for him fam that's why
my jaw dropped I didn't drop because
they went to Penn broth and a parity
some of them are banging of course
they're banging the American but [ __ ]
there was one she was only like 25 as
well 26 actually bang she was 25 26 and
then she [ __ ] a 14 year old boy that's
mad in the classroom that's Madden and
that's madness got his 13 year old
bredrin to wash the door to make sure no
one saw what she was getting railed over
the desk bra no she went G ale
she went jail but I was thinking broth
is horrible because it's such a double
standard yeah as soon as you flip it
round and say if it was a guy that you
can't even finish send it yeah yeah
you're like take him all day kill him
kill him he needs to get raped in bed
yeah dude
he's sick [ __ ] but if a Peng T if I'm a
[ __ ] 15 16 horny [ __ ] brother
when I was 15 I would have [ __ ] any of
my teachers and they were all disgusting
I got hard dick for bands in school oh
yeah man before he spoke about Brian if
a buff teacher Holling me like yo I want
to [ __ ] you I am NOT stay after class
and let me suck you off my heart would
have left my chest because you are
trying to trap me bro
literally I couldn't believe it like the
women will never understand like the mum
of the kid yeah must have thought that
he's just tortured yeah yeah dad Lucy at
14 from a teacher that it doesn't get
better than that tick
first when I was 14 I was ready to bang
yeah I don't know if I was I remember
oh that's high I don't know if I was
emotionally ready physically I was ready
I was ready I would have given anything
for one of my teachers drive up ah
that's funny but it keeps happening I
don't know what's on the water over
there but it loved it
I I've not heard any news about that to
be honest - if I don't even listen to
watchin you saw but to be fair I get
most of my News from pokers I heard
these stories from other podcasts oh wow
but yeah but there's teachers I [ __ ]
is sucking all going Joe I think of a
fight me know they're gonna go Joe and
then win - whiskey for that teenage dick
that's mind-blowing there's mind-blowing
that are willing to risk their career
their livelihood everything to suck over
a young black kid it's crazy I mean I
don't know if any of them work but I
hope they were for the related Billy I
hope they were no offense but if it's a
white guy they're all white it's boring
it's boring like this there's no sexual
it's boring you know I mean it's boring
for us like you want to relate yeah I'm
gonna imagine you with that teenager and
if everyone's white boring okay oh my
god
first of all this is actually to be fair
just to wrap this up I don't even want
to get into it because it's
controversial gonna get in trouble
yeah on the topic of if it was a male
teacher they're going jail when they do
but what's the going on with teenage
girls at a minute and their makeup on
that to be fair to be fair a lot of you
can tell when it go is young if you have
to question it don't do it it's that
simple
you have to ask the question how old she
is she leave it is jail jail don't even
question it don't just [ __ ] don't
but it's mad because a lot of the girls
or not the people I work with even girls
girls and guys they're in uni a lot of
people that I work with a lot of people
are managed to Anini because part time
job yeah and when you see them inside
work
make up and they look good hmm but when
you see them if you see them in a club
out as a little thinking [ __ ] you look
good you look good
obviously they're in Eunice so they are
of age but if you put that if you flip
that and go to America where all of them
or wear a makeup I like in year like 9
10 and 11 and all that [ __ ] when you see
them outside it's hard to determine how
old like you can you might think she's
young but within the same brief you
might think maybe she's like 21 22 but
if you have to think about it there's
girls in my gym I know that like 16 max
max max 16 max and then first of all Jim
shark is selling pedophilia Jim jock is
selling pedophilia they've got a deal
with someone to catch as many people as
they can because they're exploiting
young women's bodies that maybe shake I
wasn't expecting to say that one under
that but please note all right honestly
like you going to Jim yeah and they're
they're 16 7 like 17 max bullsh 16 in a
bit prov 16 and a half yeah
and you just like good grief well if
this someone is going to get arrested
it's all your fault all your phone this
is peak in taneous time yes of course
get all the flesh out about me me young
ones we just you know horrible you have
when you I kind of say you know we spoke
about obviously
the bloomers the late bloomers Angela
are this guy obviously Sakura from year
9 yeah yeah yeah grab these times you'll
see these girls of in gym you're like
she's 16 in like hmm well if I just
secure it now I work [ __ ] but if I
just if I just if I just manipulate our
emotions enough so that she's she needs
me
she needs me then when she tells 21 we
can chat cuz she's gonna beep if she's
unbelievably bit scary it's scary that's
why I put it on at the very very yet cuz
it needed to be a five-minute chat
before I say something are true ivory
laughed same your sweat regret rub my
said I'm here for it I'm sweaty thing is
where he choked up anything but Peter
fit is a sensitives yeah is but
comedians make jokes of it every day and
people laugh that's true so it's not
like obviously we're not condoning or
promoting or whatever and we're not
trying to say try and see the lighter
side of it it's just an awareness yeah
man it's a no where's my man you can
make the funny of anything of course
that's the thing because I was actually
listening sorry to call you it was
actually listen to it something the
other day was someone said something
that was so key and crucial and it was
like I think it might have been Ricky
Gervais and they were like he must have
said a rape joke or something
he would ever know I think yeah yeah he
was talking about woman who like heck
would him and say like do you things
rapes finally Twitter yeah yeah it's
funny I mustn't depends on the joke yeah
and that was obviously the joke yeah but
the thing is actually true yeah like
rape as a concept it's not funny [ __ ]
the fan of course not but you could make
citing about the concept of rape funny
honey yeah and it's like yeah I tried to
find the funny in India and yet like the
reason I get nervous talking about what
like that kind of stuff yeah and that
goes in the gym and stuff about you just
like I don't know how people are gonna
take this yeah I know it's a joke
yeah yeah
some people might get offended yeah but
[ __ ] I don't care about those people to
be fair I school shit's and gigs mum
that's valid my head hurts let's wrap it
up again money